Hey, guys! What's going on? So I just recently
watched the new Mulan movie from Disney and
the classic one was one of my favorites when I
was growing up so honestly I was a little bit
disappointed by what Disney decided to do with
this new version and for that reason we decided
to make a lesson for you today with the classic
one. This is a really fantastic movie to learn
with guys and today we're going to look at a
scene first off with Eddie Murphy as Mushu the
dragon a really hilarious character and then
we'll look at one of the classic songs that I
know you're going to love learning with. So before
we jump into all of that I want to let you know
that if you are new here every single week we make
new lessons with your favorite movies series and
so much more so that you can understand fast
speaking natives without getting lost, without
missing the jokes and without subtitles just
like our fan Vijay who says that thanks to our
lessons he can now understand natives even when
we speak really fast and you can too all you have
to do is hit that subscribe button and the bell
below so you don't miss any of our new lessons.
Hey again I hope you're having a lot
of fun already and if you enjoy making
learning English simple and natural
like this then I highly recommend you
don't miss out on our free three-part
masterclass now in this masterclass
we teach you the three secrets that you
need to be able to understand natives at
any speed and you can sign up absolutely free
by clicking up here or down description below.
Hey if you are enjoying this lesson
then don't forget to check out this
playlist where you can find all of our
lessons featuring different Disney movies
you can find that by clicking up
here or down the description below.
Hey if you've liked learning English with this
Disney song then I highly recommend that now
you head over to our Instagram where we have an
exclusive lesson for you where you will learn four
more common native expressions so I look forward
to seeing you over on Instagram @reallife.english